good morning John beginnings and endings
I like it I like this frame I love
beginnings I've got several beginnings
that I'm interested in
soda syrups saw anything to do with
socks I'm really into right now I've got
a couple things I'd like to end on sort
of a national level but in terms of me
things that I can act definitely do in
control I don't know what I want to end
we interview people for jobs sometimes
sometimes for fairly high level jobs I
once had as somebody come into a job
interview and be like I could get you to
acquisition in a just a couple and I was
like to act - what like building
complexly up to sell it and I was just
like oh no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no I want to be
running this company when I die I'd
really sound like a moped there for a
sec here's the thing that I would like
to end I would like to end my line edits
for my book what are lying on a tank
okay here's what book writing looks like
if you're in the traditional publishing
industry first you write a book I don't
know how this works
I don't know so you've got a manuscript
and you've got an editor however that
happened is a mystery but you got it and
you give it to the editor and either
they tell you this is trash or they
write you a letter and that's called the
editorial letter and it says this book
is not trash followed by a 22 page list
of all the ways in which the book is
trashed this is the success condition so
then you've finished your big revision
you basically rewritten the book there's
50,000 words that aren't in there
anymore and 40,000 new ones then you get
your line edits and your line edits are
like line by line your editor goes why
did you do this usually it's fairly
simple things like it's you need a
different word here because you use this
word earlier in the sentence beforehand
then occasionally you get a line at it
that basically says rewrite this chapter
and you're like this isn't allowing that
and during the line that it is for me
when I read the entire book out loud I'm
a slow reader regardless but reading out
loud is particularly slow of course
after you're lying at it you get your
copy at it that's when somebody in my
case last time the valedictorian of my
high school graduating class for some
reason Mary Beth constant just reads
your entire manuscript and tells you all
of the little things you got wrong and
it's usually much less troublesome your
to spaying like yes I agree that there
should be a common there you're right I
did use the wrong word Marybeth yes you
are still smarter than me all of these
years later this is maybe the weirdest
coincidence of my entire life I hope I
get Marybeth again there was literally a
single typo in the whole book when it
came out which is amazing at this point
you've been changing this book like
every day for six eight months you've
been looking at it and changing things
and then they say don't change anything
out and your entire mind is built to
change the book and then you have to say
no this is the final you would decide
now that all the words that are in here
deserve to be in here in none of the
words that aren't in there should be and
not a high-stress person I'm really not
I'm laid-back but that is too much that
is the biggest ending I'm working toward
in 2020 and I'm kind of terrified of it
I like this book a lot it's it's much
more ambitious than my first book and I
think that it says a lot of interesting
and important things that we need to be
saying and thinking about right now but
this is one of the great things about
creative work that you are forced to an
end so I guess I'm lucky to have a job
where I get lots of little I did it
moment whether it's finishing a book or
whether it's finishing this video John
I'll see you right now because we're on
tour together Hank you just made a whole
video about your book in which you
didn't say the name of the book which is
a beautifully foolish endeavor nor did
you say when it comes out which is July
7th and nor did you say that it's
available for pre-order now which it is